Getting a robot to fly is impressive
but once it’s in the air, how do you keep it there
without draining too much energy?
Nature’s answer is perching.
Think of perching as landing without a runway.
Birds, bats, & insects do it.
They can land on narrow surfaces, upside down
or right-side up.
Remain idle for long periods of time,
and then take off by launching themselves
from different positions.
Now researchers have made a robotic insect
that can perch by using electroadhesion.
The tiny robot is adorned with an “electrode patch”
that can create a static charge for attaching to surfaces.
It’s a similar principle to static cling from a balloon.
This type of adhesion is pretty weak, so objects
must be really light for them to stick to a surface.
To get around that limitation, scientists designed
these robots to weigh a minuscule 84mg.
That’s less than a bee! At this weight, It takes
a thousand times less power to perch than to fly.
The lightweight electrode patch combined
with a flexible, shock absorbing mount
enables the robot to perch on a variety of surfaces:
glass, wood, and even a leaf.
To detach, the electricity is turned off
allowing the patch to discharge.
Once they can fly tetherless, these perching robots could
be used to provide birds-eye views of disaster areas,
detect hazardous chemicals,
or enable communication in remote regions.
Future designs could allow for perching
on vertical surfaces,
which means we could have our first robotic
fly on the wall.